alayum Salam are you a
Muslim alhamdulillah proud man proud all
right you know quickly actually
something to you yeah so it was funny
you were just speaking about um with the
guy just previously was talking
about um people attacking
Christianity but from what I see on
YouTube especially from the YouTube
scene I see mainly people like for
example like Christians like you for
example have a channel predominantly
speaking about trying to refute
Islam like which I don't understand
really because if you're doing it for if
you're doing it for the sincerity of
actually trying to understand or even
learn or for whatever the case you're
doing it for yeah why don't you focus on
Christianity and spread the word of
Jesus I do I do I do focus on
Jesus and I do that in the midst of me
debunking Islam and exposing its lies
about
Christianity Islam has a lot to say
about Jesus it lies about Jesus it puts
words in his mouth it lies about the
prophets and so I'm defending
Christianity when I clear up the lies
and the misconceptions that Muslims have
and that the Quran puts out about about
my prophets and my
Lord so so so you don't think that the
Bible lies also on the on the prophets
or on Jesus as well say say that
again I didn't hear the beginning part
of your
question you
there
Bassel Habibi you
basil basil
no not
again oh
oh you're there sorry sorry the
connection probably put bad oh man you
scared me bro oh my
goodness I was just yeah no I was just
saying you don't
so obviously you don't anyways but you
so you don't believe that the the Bible
lies on the prophets or
Jesus of course I do that's that's
what where where we know about the from
the
Bible sorry sorry say that again I
didn't get I didn't get that how we know
about the prophets Jesus what they
believe they taught it's all in the
Bible are you there am I losing
you I think I lost him hey uh BAS try to
try to come back when your connection is
good okay cuz I I feel like we might be
able to have a good conversation oh
this yeah try try to reload everything
I'm I'mma let you go from this try to
reload and and try to come back okay I'm
gon bring somebody else up in the
meantime lo lo lo go I think should be
all right now but if it cuts out now
then yeah take me off okay but yeah
let's go um so yeah what was he saying
Sor no yeah I was I was saying that how
we know about the prophets what they
taught what they believed where they was
from right uh their stories their
situations it's all in the
Bible and you you don't you don't think
it
lies what do you think well well I'm
asking you because you're telling me
that the Quran lies on the prophets and
Jesus in particular so yes I'm just so
I'm just flipping the question on to you
you know so I'm just asking you so you
don't yeah brother yeah brother if you
know we we have Isaiah's writing Isaiah
himself is a prophet or Moses is you
know Moses wrote we have the writing
we know they taught so we know their
story we know what they taught we know
what they believed so if someone comes
later and and you know puts a words into
their mouth things they didn't say you
know beliefs into their system uh that
they didn't believe we see where the LIE
is but okay but the thing is what the
difference between the Quran and the
Bible and you can to you can agree but
you can agree to disagree on this is
that the Quran is the actual words and
the speech of Allah Almighty the Creator
the Bible on the other hand isn't from
word for word from cover to
cover it's not the word of God neither
is the Quran but and how can you and how
can you uh prove that let me ask you how
Pro okay how do you know when Muhammad
is speaking in the
Quran but that's the thing though is who
said Muhammad speaking it's all the
speech of Allah is all the almighty is
the
creator are you
sure are of course I'm sure let me give
you let me give you an example of what
I'm talking about okay
look so you have for
example if we go like 568 the Quran the
Quran mention there the stories on pares
in the Quran yes
and know exactly so that's I'm talking
about this is what I'm talking about
okay hold on let me just show you okay
show
me
[Music]
so if we have for example I'm GNA use
I'm G use 568 as an example of what I
mean all right so let me just share my
screen real quick uh let's do this okay
move this real quick all right so this
is chapter 5 verse 68 and you see how
the beginning of the verse it starts off
it says say
oh people of the
scripture you have nothing to stand to
uh You Have Nothing Till You observe the
Torah and the gospel but and so forth
and so forth but here's my point it says
say oh people of the scripture who is
Allah telling to say who is Allah
telling to talk to the people of the
scripture say oh people the scripture
he's prob he speaking to Muhammad alaih
wasallam exactly so he's speaking to
Muhammad right and then so after the say
this is what Muhammad says to the people
right okay okay so this is these are
Muhammad's words from Allah we know that
this is when the prophet starts to speak
after Allah says say okay without the
word without say we know that it's Allah
himself his own words right okay okay so
now let's use this as an example let's
go to chapter 11 let's do like verse you
I do I don't get point though my point
is is that uh not everything in the
Quran is word for word from Allah and I
don't think that and and I'm I'm just
showing you examples you literally have
entire chapter called the Jin right that
like it quotes the Jin those aren't the
words below so so so who's speaking
sorry but who's speaking then I don't
understand all right well I'll ask you
this right here I'll ask you on this one
who's speaking okay so sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry I mean look we've all
do respect brother yeah mhm you haven't
studied the Quran how do you know
that I mean have you gone have you have
you studied the Quran have you yes I
have okay and what's your what's your
what's your view and I'm about to show
you I'm about to show you that I studed
no but but when you when when I mean by
studying what you have you had read I
read the entire I read
the read the the commentary that's not a
study my brother I'm going I'm talking
about going to a teacher going I I don't
have to go to a teacher in order to stud
the well then so see this is where we
differ see this is what we I went I went
to the teachers that teach your
teachers oh wow and and your your
teachers your teachers learned from
people like Al TB
C see this is the thing I went I went to
them look and I became that's that's not
studying look at the end of the day look
the Quran the Quran is not use here for
our own interpretation no worries I'm
not going to interpret can I just show
you what I'm talking about no but so no
but so this is what I'm saying no
because you do do your own
interpretation because I'll give you for
example no there's nothing dud we're
wasting time can I just show you I'm not
gonna interpret I'm not gonna okay show
me okay show me okay cool all right look
so Alf lra this how it starts
off Alf lra a scripture the revelations
whereof are perfected and then expounded
from one un wise inform formed who's
speaking
here Allah all right Allah speaking
let's go to the next let's
continue serve none but
Allah lo I am unto you from him a Warner
and bringer of Good
Tidings hold on a second so Allah is
saying that he Allah says serve none but
Allah and that Allah is a Warner of
someone and a bringer of Good
Tidings say serve none but Allah now see
the saying is in parenthesis so that's
not part of the verse I don't even know
why they put that
there I'm trying to read the Arabic
first one second okay yeah no
worries yeah this this is from Allah
right so Allah is saying serve none but
Allah and that Allah himself is a is a
Warner
from him and a bringer of Good Tidings
who is Allah a bringer of Good Tidings
of who sent
Allah no one sent Allah I don't
understand well Allah saying I am unto
you from him a Warner and a bringer of
Good Tidings who who sent Allah who the
good tit but to be honest with this the
commentary I don't let me let me one
second okay cuz I don't I've never heard
what A pick pick who I've never seen
that before in my life so one second
before this is what happens when we
study the Quran bro no that's not
studying you're bringing sign else
that's not from the Quran I don't really
know what that what do you mean not from
the Quran this is literally from the
Quran verbo I'm not even bringing
nothing else okay just one second then
let me let me let me research one second
okay all right as as he uh gets what
he's looking for guys make sure you all
hit the like button smash it like you
fear Disobedience from it all right and
make sure you guys support the stream we
got 2900 people watching on YouTube uh
almost 400 watching on Tik Tok so we're
doing really good make sure we get all
the likes Up Guys the likes aren't
matching up okay so everybody smash that
like button let's get up to 3,000 likes
way before the stream ends guys guys
come on let's get up to 3,000 likes but
here here's the argument guys the
argument is he said that the Quran is
the verbatim speech of Allah everything
in the Quran is word for word word for
word word
of sorry go go go yeah yeah let me just
land it so everything is the word
verbatim word of Allah the problem is is
that we run into verses where if that's
the case we have Allah saying things
like this saying that he is a servant of
somebody whose name who is Allah and is
a is a Warner and a Glad Tidings Allah
is a messenger of
Allah you know there is no say matter of
fact let's make sure because I don't I
don't like that PTO got that parenthesis
there I like to stick straight to the
verse what's there in the in the Arabic
right because in the Arabic saying is
not there it's not there all right um
look right now I can't bring up for you
cuz my laptop's even dead I need to
charge it it's going to take a bit of
time it's okay Ma I'm I'm here what you
need okay one second let me try my
laptop one second I I got I got my whole
computer here for you man what you what
you need man go on go on Quran don't go
on this one go on Quran yeah and go just
go on Google and type in the translation
for that for that for that verse what do
you mean a translation oh Google
translate okay not Google translate just
go on actual Safari and just Ty in the
the the on the qur there's the actual
Quran app and has the
um oh quran.com yes yes got it okay
quran.com all right cool cool cool we
can do that we could do
that quran.com what is that 112 all
right so chapter 11 verse
two all right I said 11
okay look look at how they try to fix
this guys they put they put in the
brackets through a messenger saying stop
it it doesn't say that in the text that
is a man look at how see what you mean G
see I don't understand so something that
you don't like you're trying to change
it now I don't understand no brother no
I'm I'm actually being honest and strict
to the what the Quran says so then why
you that is what the Quran say you don't
speak Arabic so you're not going to know
exactly way it says so you don't even
know let's let this speak all right good
so you said so through a messenger
saying that means that that should be
here in the Arabic right let's see if it
says that no it's oh wait it's not there
why why is through a messenger saying
not popping up in the
Arabic like I said is quran's is Allah's
speech however he it's stories and
Parables that Allah speaks within the
Quran and then he relays verses that the
prophets say and ET however this isn't
this isn't a parable or nothing like
that this is just him talking
yeah he's relaying what Muhammad s what
Muhammad s Al was would be saying to the
people but we say that whenever he and
and it said literally in Brackets there
through a messenger saying hold on hold
on hold on a second we don't bring me
that one because that one clearly bring
we just saw whenever Allah is telling
wants Muhammad to address something he
said don't me don't give me that s okay
go on the other side go on the same side
on the right one and bring up the same
verse okay and watch it it's gonna say
say
watch yeah but I don't get I don't get
your point that
doesn't is is that thean don't help no
hold on that don't help you in any way
you don't even understand the point you
don't even understand the point
I hate what you're trying to say you're
trying to say that it's not it's not
word for word Allah is saying who is
speaking exact exactly but I'm saying to
it's the speech of Allah tala those
verses he's it's like he tolds them he
tells them what they're gonna say look
look bro I got it over here these the
Revelation the Revelation BR relax hold
on bro relax I mean see how see in the
Arabic how it says say even exactly say
all people the scripture that's
568 when Muhammad is being told to say
something when Allah wants him to convey
something he tells Muhammad say but do
we see him say say in 112 no it's not
there but then okay but then what does
it say in Brackets though I don't care
what it says in Brackets that's not in
the
verse well then you have to be in
context and what they're talking about
because then it will show you we know
what talking in context is talking about
Allah is speaking as you said Allah is
speaking and he's talking about the
verses of the Quran Al this this book
whose verses are perfected and presented
in detail from uh wise and aware right
Allah speaking and then Allah continues
do not worship except Allah indeed I am
to you from him a Warner and a bringer
of Good Tidings are those Allah's words
or are those Muhammad's yeah but yeah
but like just shows you right there it
says in bracket saying brother are these
are these Allah's words or are these
Muhammad's those are those are Allah's
words but clearly I so then Allah so
then Allah saying that he's a Warner and
a messenger so who is Allah a messenger
of he's not he's not me who's that
messenger of yes who's the messenger of
no nobody because but he says here do
not worship except Allah indeed I am
this is Allah speaking I am to you from
him you know a Warner you want to
dismiss what he saying on the left side
at the end of the day I'm not I'm not an
expert in Arabic
are you not seeing what he's saying on
the left side though what left side what
are you talking look I'm look I'm an
expert in Arabic literature anyways but
I know if someone is to read that in
Arabic W did you not did you not suggest
that I use this website okay but like I
said to on the left side it says freom
messenger Sayan
so I don't get it I don't get it like I
don't get okay so maybe maybe you're
playing dumb with me so I'm gonna give
you another chance to playing okay so
don't play dumb we have the Arabic at
the top
right right yes we do have the Arabic at
the top okay then we have the
translation of the Arabic right here in
the verse yeah brother you not listen to
hold on a second just follow me for a
second I'm not against you just follow
me I'm trying to help here we have the
brackets you understand that the
brackets are not part of the verse
correct okay the brackets are what is
added in by the particular translator
the commentator he adds what he puts
into the verse so the the part that's in
Brackets is not part of the actual verse
you understand okay so ignore the
brackets it doesn't
exist this is why when we hover over the
actual Arabic the brackets is not there
show me verse underneath as well let me
see let me see the verse underneath
so it's just and seek again brackets
again so we're not going to do the
brackets see what like you IE reward
that's not in the Quran that's not what
it says so it's just continuing what he
says okay so going back
here Allah is speaking according to you
these are Allah's words not Muhammad's
these are Allah's words so Allah is
saying that Allah
is a Warner from him from
who bro it it shows is the is literally
showing you there on the left like I
said okay all right I don't want to go
into too much detail in this verse
because I don't that's all right thanks
for coming okay but let me ask you a
question y that's it that's it that's it
so what about all the proof and what
about all the proof
that's one one one one one last thing
what about all the proof and evidence
thanks for coming